hey guys Joey here say force which might
seem a little easy at first but you
might encounter some quirks along the
way our tips here will help to get
better acquainted with Nintendo's new
hardware now if you like this video and
would like to see more push content
including our review leave us a like and
subscribe to us on YouTube but for now
there are 5 tips to help you get started
with your switch
now first tip for you is how to attach
and detach the joi con controllers from
the switch console now attaching them is
fairly simple all you have to do is take
them and then slide them down the rails
on the side so you hear that snap stand
with the other side like that and as for
removing them it's a little bit trickier
on the backside of the console this is a
small black button that you have to
press in and then lift out right here
like that
[Music]
so next tip we have for you is how to
attach the wrist strap for the joy pong
controllers now you want to make sure
the plus and minus symbols are lined up
on each respective side that that simple
enough now for removing them you don't
actually have to press the button in the
back all you have to do is take it slide
it right out
so our next tip for you is how to pair
the pro controller with a Nintendo
switch now you can do it with the
included USB cable plug it into the top
of the controller and then the bottom of
the system or you can do it wirelessly
in order to do that you'll need to go
into the options menu and you will go
all the way down to controllers and
sensors and then hit change grip order
and you want to press the sync button on
the top of the pro controller and you
hear that beep that's a L&R button and
you're ready to go and our next tip for
you is how to get a more accurate
battery readout for your switch there is
a little icon that will loosely tell you
how much power is left but all you have
to do is tap it and while it only
appears for a second you'll get the
actual percentage of how much power you
have left and so for a final tip I'm
going to show you how to insert a micro
SD card so the slot is a little bit
difficult to find but it's actually
right here underneath the kickstand so
you want to lift that up take the SD
card
snap it in there you go so that's it
those are our five tips to help you get
started with your switch if this video
is helpful for you make sure leave us a
like and subscribe to us on YouTube for
more swished content
[Music]
you